To answer this question, let's look at the scatter plot--you see there're certain sizes of people
and then there are certain weights associated with these people, and it's hard to make out
but I think there's a dependance whereby the taller a person is the heavier the person is.
Now, there's lots of exceptions--this person is a remarkably heavy person for size,
this is a remarkably light person for about the same size, and we all know that some people are
heavier and thinner and thicker for these sizes, but if you'll expectively, you can see a slight
upper trend that appears to be approximately linear.
We can't tell this right now--we don't understand how to analyze
where the data depends as a linear but you get the juice of it.
By looking at the data alone, you can tell that weight increases with size.
So for now, I'll check the second box over here because the other ones are obviously incorrect.